Let me,
my life for the last year has been so
busy that I haven't had proper time to
reflect on what's been happening.
And even if I did,
I wouldn't,
I'm not exactly sure I would be able to
understand it anyways because it isn't
sure I'm not,
I don't think I have a framework of
reference within which to put it.
So I started working for this company
called Television TV Ontario about 1516
years ago.
I had talked to a producer,
his name was Waldeck Shimberg,
he's emigrate,
Polish Jew and a really smart guy.
And he phoned me up at the university.
And one of the things that distinguishes
me to some degree from my colleagues is
that I'll talk to the press and that I'm
actually not afraid of them or
distrustful love them.
Like a lot of my colleagues,
not all of them are like,
they're critical of the press,
partly in an arrogant way and partly in
a defensive way.
They say,
well,
they always get it wrong.
It's like,
well,
first of all there isn't that they and
they don't always get it wrong.
And you know,
they,
they'll also shy away from the press as
if they're being intruded upon when the
truth is generally speaking,
the ideas that they're putting forward
aren't of sufficient interest to draw
public attention anyways.
And so,
but I talked to what EC for a long time
and he invited me to go on a couple of,
of shows and then uh,
then I ended up on [inaudible] the
agenda,
which is a pretty good public affairs
show.
It's one of the few,
I would say deep new shows left that
that are on normal broadcast TV and you
know,
they go into issues in some depth,
although they fragmented that up a bit
in recent years.
And I became a fairly common guest on
those shows and people seem to like what
I was saying,
which always surprised me.
I mean,
but,
but it was good because you know,
it must be pretty damn horrible to put
yourself out in the public eye and face
primary criticism for what you're doing.
I think that would be unbearable in some
sense unless you were very,
very strongly constituted.
And then,
well that went on for awhile and we'll
deck was running this a series called
big ideas,
which was actually quite prescient,
you know,
so he had lecturers come to Toronto and,
and he had all pretty much all the major
public intellectuals in the world over a
period of about five years or six years
or so,
come and deliver bare bones lectures of
this sort fundamentally need taped them
and put them on TV,
you know,
and,
and uh,
that was sort of unheard of.
The production quality was well high but
not overproduced weren't multiple
cameras and edits and,
and intelligent commentary from people
in the background.
It was purely content driven,
you know,
and it actually got pretty popular on,
on iTunes and you can still find the
lectures there,
but Tvo couldn't they,
they,
they pulled the show even though their
primary mandate from the government was
to educate the public.
And this was a very low budget show with
very high quality minds that people were
actually watching and downloading a lot
on iTunes.
But they,
they didn't seem to take the non
standard media with any degree of
seriousness.
And you know,
that's kind of a common human attribute,
which is that if you don't know about
something,
you don't take it seriously.
Right.
And it's,
it's,
cause if you don't know about it,
well,
it's just gray and fuzzy,
right?
You have no differentiated knowledge.
So it's easy to oversimplify it.